okay so just well I meant kind of that
way but you know it took ages so we're
going to talk about shapes of constant
width this is what I want to show you
and to show you I've built a sort of
diorama well what I've done I've stuck a
lego man to a ruler so there it is and I
want you to imagine that you're this
Lego man it's annoying
you've been stuck to a ruler so you
can't move around but you have the idea
maybe if I put some shapes between the
ruler and the ground I'll be able to
move around and so you experiment in
different ways the first thing you try
maybe is some hexagons they see the
hexagons they don't work very well
because as the hexagons rotate the
height changes and it's a bumpy ride so
hexagons are not shapes of constant
width or height they're shapes of
non-constant with non constant height so
Brady what shape would I have to put in
there to make this work well I'm
obviously like a circle oh yeah greatest
invention of all time there is because
the reason that works is as a circle
rotates the height stays the same the
width stays the same and that's the only
shape that can work right that's why
circles around it wouldn't work with a
square it would work with a triangle
would it work with a triangle but if we
sort of rounded the faces a little bit
probably not well let's try that so
these these are called r-la uh triangles
I might not be pronouncing that right
someone correct me in the comments I'm
sure you will so here it is right so
they're not circles but they're the same
height all the way around at the same
width all the way around no matter how
you turn these shapes they are the same
width even though they're not circles
yeah when I first saw that I kind of
blew my mind a little bit it's cool
isn't it skipping past it
my wheels like that okay so actually the
reason we don't make wheels like this is
because if you put a central axis in
there you would bump bump up and down
because the distance from the center to
the edge does change so this is going to
talk to the bottom that doesn't change
actually someone has built a bike it was
to commemorate the Beijing Olympics I
think a few years ago and the the frame
of the bike
rested on top of the wheels and so this
shape of wheel could then work in that
situation it's also used in something
called a Wankel engine but we want to
talk about that I'll show you how to to
make one of these you take an odd sided
shape say a triangle like this and I'm
using an equilateral triangle and you
just round off the faces as if you've
got a compass you put the compass point
on on one of the corners and then sort
of go like that and then like that and
then like that so let's just do the guy
that like that like that if you started
with a seven sided shape then you end up
with 50p coins so 15 coins are shapes of
constant width if you get ahold of two
50p coins and a couple of books for
example and roll the books around that
they will stay the same distance apart
because even though they're not circles
50p coins are shapes of constant width
well they make them like that because
they can and it's an interesting thing
but coins have to be shapes of constant
width to work in vending machines
vending machines measure the width of a
coin as it goes through so if that were
to change the vending machine wouldn't
know necessarily what coin you're
putting in so you can make coins this
way so they do so that's the that's the
relly Oh triangle or reloj triangle I
think I've drawn that quite well look
that's amazing I don't believe that very
impressed you can't get this so you can
take any triangle and turn it into a
shape of constant width this one is a 3
4 5 triangle and so it shows you
actually that how you have to lengthen
the edges here so that's a that's a
single unit extended there and two units
extended out there
I actually got quite obsessed about this
when I started to think about is there a
three-dimensional equivalent
to this so the three-dimensional
equivalent of a circle is sphere so if
you take three now spheres I can roll
this around on here like that the plane
of the table and the plane of this board
stay the same distance apart because
spheres are solids of constant width
record but there are three-dimensional
equivalents of shapes of constant width
that are non spherical the way to make
them is you take like what one of these
and you make a solid of rotation like
that so you just spin it around and it
sweeps out a three-dimensional shape so
this is a shape that you can turn on a
lathe so I went online and I had a look
around as anyone does anyone have these
things eventually came across a book
called how round is your circle behind
John Brian and Chris sanguine they had
some of these shapes on the front cover
and I said you know can I get some of
these I sitting it's in Chris and email
trying to find the email actually I said
something like you know I love your
shapes of constant width where did you
get them and he said well I had
thousands made with an educational grant
how many would you like
so he sent me a whole lot in about 50
and his three of them here it's a shape
of constant width that been rotated into
a solid of constant width and so they
work as well so there you go now I was
very happy with that but then if you
look at the front cover of Chris
sanguinis book I recommend you check it
out his solids of constant width on
metal and and they're pointy as well
these have been cleverly rounded to make
them wear a bit better but I wanted some
I wanted some metal ones I want them to
be pointy so I searched around on the
internet and eventually found a forum
for lady enthusiasts and they all said
it can't be done you can't do this it's
not something you can turn on a lathe
and then I got brilliantly I got a
private message from one guy saying I'll
do it for you - these are my metallic
solids of constant width Wow
so what I do with these I put them I
line them up and I stand on this and I
roll around on them not just for fun I
mean for shows us too and for fun
you can't say that just drop that and
then not do it really yeah
okay now we are on a bit of carpet so it
might not work as well but well I might
need someone to give me a pusher and how
you feel about that okay so just well I
meant kind of that way but you know it's
okay okay so push me towards these extra
ones here yeah that's it yeah that's it
yeah there's an infinite number of those
as well because again I could take that
the Pentagon and rotate that and that
would become one I could take you know
the 50p coin and rotating that would be
one or the nine sided shape with evan
side you take whatever but there is a
more interesting example which is
instead of just doing a solid of
rotation which well it's a bit like
cheating so if you take the
three-dimensional equivalent of a
triangle which is a tetrahedron and
round off the faces of that then it's
actually not quite a sort of constant
width you have to round off three of the
edges as well so this doesn't have it's
not solid of rotation anymore it has
less symmetry it's even more kind of
counterintuitive it seems less like it
could be a solid of constant width and
it's called a maizena tetrahedron you
can't get these turned on a lathe but
here they are made in plastic you can
see we've got three slightly rounded
edges which is something you have to do
to get it to work three straight edges
like that or sharp edges should I say
and then basically rounded off faces
using the OP again using the opposite
corner as a guide so that point there is
the centre of this sphere here and so
these are believe it or not solids of
constant width
nice and that's a nice oddity yeah is
these useful just to engineers and
people use these for anything and
engineers use the the radio triangle or
Rolo triangle in the Wankel engine and
that's that's about oh you can you
there's a drill as well with it's got it
uses that triangle in there somewhere
and you can use it to cut a square hole
you can drill a square hole with it yeah
one thing I thought is maybe ball
bearings that won't roll away you can
put it on a slope and it doesn't where
it's going to slide because it's
slipping but it's it's not going to roll
because the center of mass is really low
it that could be it or something but
yeah right give it a well so I know what
you're all thinking
where can I get my very own shape or
solid of constant width and the answer
is Steve and the guys at maths gear have
had them made for you check it out that
is the ultimate geeky Christmas present
right there what a great little stocking
filler I get no Commission from this I'm
just saying that's a great present I'd
love to have one of them under the tree
I think the shapes here come in wood or
acrylic and here's the solids I've put a
link in the video description you're
crazy if you don't check it out